[Music]
the pond looked dark
even now even in broad daylight muriel
remembered it always looked dark
she had always been afraid of it she
waded through layers of dead leaves in
her worn black flats
keeping her eyes fixed on the still
water the grass around the pond had
grown long and wild
muriel wondered if there were snakes her
parents had always kept the house and
grounds immaculate
and it saddened her to see the neglect
the desolation
times had been hard for them since she'd
left home and now they were gone
a cloud passed over the sun and in the
ensuing greyness muriel thought she saw
a shadow flickering just below the
surface of the pond
she stopped and looked harder but there
was nothing
her parents had always warned her to
stay away from the pond and unspoken but
understood in their stern pale warnings
was the knowledge that muriel's brother
had drowned there many years ago
when he was no more than a baby but even
if that hadn't happened
muriel would have stayed away because
when she was a little girl
she thought she'd seen things in the
pond
she scoffed at herself now standing
ankle deep in old leaves
wearing a shabby black funeral dress
whose cheap fabric stretched taut over
her swollen belly
she was a grown woman with a 13 year old
daughter and a second child on the way
a woman who had once been beautiful but
now bore the marks of two failed
marriages
abandonment single motherhood she was no
longer the terrified little girl who had
peered out her bedroom window under the
maple trees
and sworn she'd seen shadows moving
beneath the water
shadows that looked like people with
long flowing hair
she had left that little girl far behind
perhaps still in this house with its
memories
so why was she still afraid i'm not
afraid
she said it out loud then reddened and
turned to see if her daughter had heard
her talking to herself
the house and yard were silent but her
words seemed to echo through the open
stillness
coming back to her as oddly warped
sing-song a children's chant repeated
like a mantra
and she wasn't afraid she told herself
she could walk right up to the edge of
the pond now if she wanted to
just to show those shadows those
long-haired people who weren't there
that she was brave with every step
closer the shadows seemed to move faster
more erratically muriel told herself
that she didn't see them
instead she thought of her brother's
tiny white body floating and lifeless
a shock of white against the night black
water she hadn't actually seen him drown
all those years ago
but her parents had told her what had
happened and after that she'd seen it
every night in her dreams
the baby's bluish limbs splayed on the
surface of the water
the blacker shadows milling below it as
though making a nest for the egg-like
little corpse
muriel had seen it many times among her
many dreams
she was at the edge of the pond now the
water chuckled and gurgled
then seemed to lunge at her feet with
its icy black fingers
muriel jumped back then turned around
and made her way quickly back to the
house
do me a favor and stay away from that
pond angel
muriel found herself using the same tone
of voice her mother had always used
she smiled but it was a sad smile edged
with bitterness
i know i know my almost uncle died in
there angel was only half listening
her head poking into the refrigerator
her tight jeans riding so low on her
hips that the waistband of her underwear
showed
muriel had a sudden urge to smack the
girl but she restrained it
that's right the fetus in her belly
stirred then kicked
and muriel winced only another week or
two she told herself
she didn't know if the baby was a boy or
a girl she decided to let it be a
surprise
not that it really mattered anyway its
father was long gone
just as angels was her luck with men had
been little short of catastrophic for as
long as she cared to remember
angel was smearing jelly on a piece of
bread already thickly spread with peanut
butter
she sat at the kitchen table across from
muriel squashing another slice of bread
on top of the mess
and then bringing the dripping sandwich
to her mouth and taking a noisy bite
mom how come he never brought me here
she asked around a slobbering mouthful
muriel didn't answer it first what could
she say
it wasn't because she hadn't gotten
along with her parents she had
even though she'd kept her distant since
angel was born
was it the house itself that had kept
her away the stately but fading colonial
that had suddenly become a showplace
after her brother's death
the barren fields that had suddenly and
copiously born fruit
the pond with its lapping black
life-taking waters
she wasn't sure i suppose i just kind of
lost touch with your grandma and grandpa
over the years sweetie
she finally said you know how it is they
had their life we had ours
angels snorted yeah some life
despite a face that was still pink and
plump with childhood
the girl looked hard and cynical far
beyond her years
muriel knew that the words were meant to
make her feel guilty and they did
although they made her angry too she had
struggled to give angel the best life
possible under the circumstances
and even though there were times when
fate seemed against her she felt she
done a decent job
she couldn't help but resent angel a
little for throwing her failings back
into her face
i'm sorry muriel wasn't sure if that was
entirely true
but she was too tired to argue i should
have brought you to meet them
i should have done better angel shrugged
still chewing then looked away out the
kitchen window toward the pond
i wonder how deep it is she amused
almost to herself
the baby a boy was born less than a week
later
muriel drove herself to the hospital
angel silent in the seat beside her
she named the boy william after her
drowned brother and she brought him home
to her parents old house
and put him in the same room that the
first william had slept in before he
died
she didn't know exactly why she did it
although she told herself that it didn't
matter
that her brother's old room was as good
as any other
william ii was a very good baby and
slept most of the time
nonetheless muriel spent hours in the
nursery with him watching him sleep
sometimes she would sit in the rocking
chair by the nursery window and stare
out at the pond
which now seemed darker and deeper than
ever sometimes she thought she saw
choppy little waves
disturbances in the middle of the pond
as if a school of piranha was attacking
its prey just beneath the surface of the
water
she saw this on several successive days
and on each day the disturbance seemed
ever so slightly closer to the shore
she wondered if there was a large fish
living there or maybe an alligator
muriel moved her bed into the nursery
and slept directly beneath the window
when william was nearly a month old
there came a night when angel came to
the nursery door
her eyes very white and shiny in the
darkness she was clutching a stuffed
rabbit in her arms
just as she had done when she was very
small muriel beckoned
and the girl came and curled up in the
narrow bed next to her mother
deliberately keeping her back to the
window i thought i saw something
she whispered squeezing her eyes shut
tight so the tears popped out through
the cracks in the lids
there was something out there in the
pond muriel stroked the girl's hair
until she fell into a fitful sleep
then she looked out the window there
were so many of them
more than she remembered and as she
stared at them
into their greenish eyes that glowed
like fish scales in the night
she realized that she did remember what
all those years ago had really happened
to the first william her baby brother
the memory was so clear that she didn't
understand how she could have ever
forgotten it
how she could have ever believed that
the boy had drowned how she could have
believed it so wholeheartedly that she'd
had nightmares about it for many years
afterwards
she remembered her parents chalk white
faces fearful
horrified yet was there also resignation
behind those expressions
perhaps even acceptance the women had
come out of the water
and ringed the house just as they were
doing now
their skin was white like fish bellies
and patchy with algae and what looked
like barnacles
their hair hung long and wet and ropey
framing their hideous faces
covering their sagging naked breasts
they were not smiling but they gave the
distinct impression of glee
and muriel remembered thinking then that
if the women opened their mouths
several rows of razor teeth would
glimmer in the moonlight
in a moment mariel knew one of the women
would step forward
only this single action marking her as
the leader
as a girl muriel had a watch from her
second story window as her parents
stepped forward also
meeting the soaking hag halfway muriel
could not hear what was said
if indeed any words had been spoken the
moon had been nearly full that night
its pregnant yellow form like a
spotlight against the purple drape of
sky
a stage setting for the horror unfolding
by the pond
the feeded smell from the water was so
powerful that it seemed to be oozing
through the window glass
down below in the yard her parents were
stretching their arms out to the woman
and at the end of their arms lay william
pink and writhing
his little face squinched up in
consternation
muriel thought she could almost hear him
wailing although it might have been the
wind in the eaves
the woman took the infant from his
parents grasp and cradled it tenderly
staring down at it with her iridescent
eyes the other women gathered around
craning their necks to get a better look
the leader
the one holding the baby nodded once to
muriel's parents
as if to indicate that everything was
satisfactory and then she turned her
back to them
holding the baby tight against her slick
weight body
muriel's parents turned away also and
headed back toward the house
muriel had kept watching from her window
and watching from the window now a grown
woman in her old house with her own two
children sleeping beside her
she shivered to think what she had seen
then after her parents had turned away
she glanced over at william ii snoring
in his crib
his tiny hands balled into fists on
either side of his nearly hairless head
she could not bear it now seeing both
him and the memory of what had happened
to her brother
superimposed in her mind like paintings
on translucent
paper it was so horrible and yet
muriel had seen those women in the
moonlight their scaly backs like
eelskins
she had seen them all as they set upon
her brother the first little william
and even though she couldn't hear
anything she could see their muscles
working as they tore him limb from limb
see their jaws ratcheting up and down as
they masticated the tender flesh
see the splashes of blood on their
claw-like hands rendered black by the
light of the moon
and she could imagine the sounds of meat
rending of the women grunting with
satisfaction
and smacking their lips muriel saw
all these things and she never told
anyone
the next morning her parents told her
that william had fallen in the pond and
drowned
and they said no more about it muriel
had simply nodded and kept silent
perhaps he had drowned after all perhaps
what she had seen from her window had
been a dream
nothing more the day after that her
parents received word that a distant
relative had died
and left them a substantial sum of money
enough to pay off all their debts and to
make the farm prosperous once again
they were overjoyed but their eyes were
still haunted
and would stay that way until muriel
left home years later
she could not remember a time when their
faces were not hollow and furtive
when their glances did not quickly shift
back and forth
constantly searching for something that
muriel could never see
angel stirred in the bed beside her and
muriel held her until she stilled
then she looked out of the window again
the women were still there
a phalanx of corpse white statues their
sopping hair unmoved by the breeze
their peacock feather eyes raised to
meet hers
muriel understood they didn't want the
baby
not yet they wanted to bargain with her
she tiptoed quietly down the stairs
wincing every time the wood creaked
beneath her weight
she was afraid but under the
circumstances quite calm
it's almost as if i've been expecting
this she thought
in a way she supposed part of her had
been
the moonlight looked almost like chalk
where it fell upon the floorboards and
the moldy smell of the pond was like a
thick fog
muriel covered her nose and mouth with
her hand
through the downstairs windows she could
see some of the women silhouetted
against the darkness
the moonlight giving them pale glowing
auras
her stomach clenching muriel opened the
front door and stepped outside
it was a warm night but her skin was icy
and dobbed with beads of freezing sweat
the leader of these horrible women these
water witches
was still standing slightly outside of
the ring closer to the house
and when muriel emerged the hag shuffled
even closer through the long grass
muriel noticed that the woman's fingers
and toes bore bluish membranes of skin
between them
like frog's feet the sight made her
gorge rise
you know us when the woman spoke her
carp-like lips barely moved
her voice seemed deep and green and
coated with slime
marielle opened her mouth to respond but
for a moment no sound came out
her throat had gone completely dry she
coughed nervously
i remember you she finally managed
then you know what we want the hag's
eyes glittered like sapphires
muriel hadn't known what she was going
to say to the woman but before she knew
it she was sobbing
begging please she said her vision
blurred by the unbidden tears
her voice cracking please don't take my
baby
the hag looked at her the monstrous
white face expressionless
we would of course make it worth your
while she purred
just as we did with your parents muriel
recalled the sudden wealth
the farm's startling prosperity after
that horrific night
and for the briefest moment she was
tempted even though she also remembered
those empty haunted looks that had
thereafter never left her parents faces
she couldn't deny it she was disgusted
with herself
the woman was still staring at her and
the others remained in their moveless
ring
infinitely patient as though the dawn
would never come
and perhaps it wouldn't through some of
their witchery perhaps the yellow moon
would hang there in the velvet sky until
doomsday
until muriel had finally consented to
their desires
and what if i don't her voice hitched
her throat threatened to close
but she forced herself to go on what if
i don't give him to you
the lead hag's expression didn't change
but muriel got the feeling that the air
around her had grown thicker
heavier it pressed into her nose and
mouth smelling like stagnant water and
algae
creeping into her lungs and growing
there like fungus
she gasped her breath we will take the
boy regardless
the crohn hissed through her white
grouper lips had you given him to us
willingly we would have shown you our
gratitude
since you resist you will incur our
wrath and the boy will die anyway
muriel was shaking all over but she
tried to sound defiant
all we have to do is leave she cursed
herself for sounding as frightened as
she was
it occurred to her that angel might have
awakened and could be watching the
entire scene from the nursery window
she didn't dare turn to look the hag's
lips pulled apart
in what might have been a smile on a
less inhuman face
her teeth were small and triangular and
close together
a piranha's teeth our curse will find
you wherever you go
she said softly muriel shook her head
seeing the unending row of white witch's
forms as an indistinct blur in the
silvery moonlight
i don't believe you she said and the
minute the words had come out of her
mouth
the suffocating pond fog seemed to lift
and she could breathe again
a moment later she realized she was
standing in the yard alone in the middle
of the night in her bare feet
and that it was cold far colder than she
remembered it being
the grass was wet between her toes a
moment after that she was blinking awake
clear sunlight pouring in through the
nursery windows angels snoring quietly
beside her
muriel lay very still relishing the
morning and the sensation of rebirth it
brought
and then william began fussing and she
got out of bed to tend to him
when angel awoke and came down to
breakfast a little over an hour later
she seemed to have no recollection of
the night before or if she did she was
choosing to hide it
she gave her mother a cursory glance
before sitting down at the table
and tucking into a bagel and an
overflowing bowl of cornflakes
all the while scanning the pages of a
fashion magazine she held in her free
hand
mariel watched the girl for a few
minutes william perched in the crook of
her arm
angel she said it last it's time for us
to be getting back home
school will be starting in a few weeks
and i'd like to get this house put up
for sale before too long
angel barely looked up from her magazine
when are we going
today there's really no reason for us to
stay around here is there
nope angel took a long swig of her
orange juice
william began to squirm and muriel moved
him to her other arm
we can stay in a hotel tonight then
tomorrow when we get back to the city we
can start looking for another apartment
okay whatever angel drank the last of
the milk out of her bowl
and then left the dishes where they lay
and stomped back up the stairs to her
room
a few seconds later marielle heard a
dora close up there
and then the muffled beat from her
daughter's old stereo
did she remember anything muriel
wondered as she picked up the dishes
maneuvering william's tiny body to
accomplish the task
perhaps the girl had rationalized the
events away as simply a bad dream
that seemed ridiculous in the sunlight's
cruel glare or perhaps she had done what
muriel herself had done
all those years ago completely blocked
out everything she had seen
after the dishes were washed muriel put
william in his carrier where she could
keep an eye on him
then proceeded to pack all of their
things into her two battered suitcases
she hadn't brought much she hadn't even
intended to stay here as long as they
had
though she knew there would be practical
matters to be sorted out
she felt guilty that she hadn't even
contacted a realtor or the lawyers about
the sale of the property
but then she mollified herself with the
thought that william had come along
early
and caring for him had been taking up
nearly all of her time
this was true as far as it went but she
still couldn't completely excuse herself
she sighed resenting william's father
and angels for that matter
for leaving her to carry the entire
burden alone
as she packed she tried desperately not
to think of the real reason for their
swift departure
she didn't want to think of it of what
would happen if what the hag said had
been true
that the curse would follow muriel
wherever she went but that was silly
wasn't it
the women lived in the pond and surely
their influence couldn't extend far
beyond its parameters could it
besides how would they even know where
muriel had gone
as she folded her clothes and laid them
in the suitcase she noticed that her
hands were trembling
she glanced over at william who had
dozed off in his carrier
his black eyelashes fluttered against
his cherub cheeks
and his lips pouted outward from a sweet
fat little face
muriel couldn't imagine handing him over
to those horrible women with their blue
metallic eyes and their dripping piranha
teeth
she felt a wave of revulsion and hatred
toward her parents for their cowardice
forgiving the first baby william to the
hags without even a single look back
for accepting the rewards the women
bestowed upon them guiltily perhaps but
definitively
why hadn't her parents fought to keep
their son was it simply fear
or were they also blinded by their greed
their desire for a better life
muriel couldn't remember despising her
parents as much as she did in that
moment
as she watched her own son sleeping in
the early afternoon sunshine slanting
through the windows
his tiny fists curled at his sides his
expression
slack and peaceful yes i'm afraid of
them too
muriel thought maybe even more afraid of
them than my parents were
but they're not getting william not this
time
by six that evening they were all
settled in a shabby but fairly clean
motel room a few miles out of town
almost 70 miles from the farm they'd
left behind
if angel wondered about the abruptness
of their departure she didn't mention it
the second she set foot in the motel
room she tossed her bags on the floor
kicked off her shoes and flopped onto
one of the two double beds
clicking on the tv with a remote that
was bolted to the bedside table
muriel wanted to ask angel if she
remembered what had happened the night
before but she didn't quite dare
the house and its black pond were still
too close she could feel the swampy
rancid tang of them still clinging to
her skin
she could ask her about it once they
were far far away once the place had
been sold and hopefully raised to the
ground
the pond drained and filled and
forgotten for a moment muriel almost
laughed
thinking of those fearsome water witches
choking under tons of bulldozed earth
but then she envisioned the shifting
pearly eyes of the hags
the sight of their algae-coated fingers
reaching for the first baby william
the animal sounds of them tearing the
child into bloodied scraps of meat
muriel's laugh dried up in her throat
she fed the baby
then put him in his carrier and propped
him up next to her in the second double
bed
he'd been fidgeting and crying for most
of the drive here but now he seemed
calmer
and stared at the flickering television
screen with wrapped attention for a
little while
until his lid slowly closed angel
likewise dozed off
fully clothed and still lying on her
stomach on top of the covers
muriel carefully leaned over and turned
off the light above angel's bed
then pushed the off button on the remote
in the ensuing darkness and silence she
could hear the steady comforting stream
of traffic rushing by outside
as well as the rhythmic snores of her
two children
orange shafts of light from the street
lamps ringing the parking lot etched
lines of fire across the walls
muriel was so tense that she thought
she'd never be able to fall asleep
but she must have at some point for some
unknown span of time later she snapped
out of an amorphous
nightmare to find the room in total
blackness
the streetlights appeared to have gone
out and even the sounds of the traffic
outside had utterly ceased
struggling to fend off the creeping
panic muriel groped in the dark on the
bed beside her
searching for william's carrier her
frantic hands met nothing but air
and with mounting horror she realized
that the bed she lay on felt cold and
strange
as if it were covered with slime she
tried to cry out to call to angel but
her tongue seemed to have swollen
filling her mouth and all she could
manage was a strangled gasp
she turned over on her stomach reaching
up toward the light switch that she knew
must be there
only inches from her fingers but in the
darkness she could get no bearings and
her hands simply waved blindly
futile finding no solid purchase
panic had set in fully now muriel could
feel it immobilizing her limbs
sending her rational thoughts swirling
and screaming into the abyss
she was no longer in the motel room
anymore she didn't know where she was
and william and angel were gone the
smell of the cursed pond assaulted her
nostrils and she gagged
rolling to escape it and falling landing
with a thump on one elbow
which made an upsetting crunch before
sending shards of jagged glass pain into
the space behind her eyes
moaning she reached out with her good
arm and grasped something that felt like
wet fabric
the bottom of a bed spread she almost
cried with relief
she was still in the motel room after
all maybe there had been a blackout and
she had awakened in the middle of it
she hadn't been able to find william on
the bed next to her but it was very dark
she'd been half asleep disoriented
regaining her senses somewhat muriel
used the bedspread to help haul herself
into a sitting position
her elbow was throbbing possibly broken
but her relief was like a soothing tide
blotting out the pain almost entirely it
was still so dark that muriel may as
well have been staring at thick black
velvet drapes hanging inches from her on
all sides
not a speck of light penetrated anywhere
and the smell of the pond was still as
heavy as syrup
sweating and cursing muriel pulled
herself to her feet and almost
immediately went sprawling
unable to orient herself in a world with
no visual cues
she finally stood upright shakily not
daring to move a step
angel she called her voice seemed
swallowed by the immensity of the
darkness
but the sound was still so startling
that muriel's heart skipped several
beats
angel louder this time the girl was a
deep sleeper
muriel knew that but she was disturbed
when she got no answer
she held her breath and listened hard in
the blackness craning her head toward
where she thought angel's sleeping form
should be but there was nothing
she may as well have been the last human
alive floating in the vast nothingness
of space
and then for a moment she thought she
did hear something a rush
a sigh muriel flapped her arms
desperately around in the blackness
nearly losing her balance again the
sound could have been her imagination
or it could have been angel or the baby
somehow she knew though
in the depth of her gut that it was
neither of these things
she knew that something was wrong as she
stood
frozen in her dreadful certainty there
was another sound that could have been a
laugh
and then a blast of frigid air rushed
past her face
air that stank of the pond a thick green
rotten stench that brought the water
hag's countless army clearly into her
mind's eye
she flailed again almost falling her
elbow protesting with every movement
and her hands finally met something
solid slamming up against it with such
force that she nearly screamed
it was a wall and muriel leaned against
it pressing her palms flat against the
textured wallpaper
silently thanking gods she had stopped
believing in on that night when her baby
brother had been taken away
moving slowly her heart thudding like a
jackhammer in her chest
she felt her way along the wall until
her fingers met what could only be a
light switch
crowing with triumph she flipped it then
had to close her eyes for a few seconds
at the sudden brightness
before she opened her eyes she realized
that the blackout theory was obviously
incorrect
her body felt as though it was filled
with lead she opened her eyes
reluctantly
the wallpaper was just as she remembered
beige and speckled with tiny shards like
diamond chips
it looked blurry this close up feeling
as though she were in a slow-motion
nightmare she turned and surveyed the
room
the bedspreads and carpet both an
undistinguished shade of orangish tan
were now spattered with an olive green
mucus-like slime
a stinking layer of algae-covered
seaweed coating the surfaces like rancid
frosting
the smell of stagnant water hung so
thickly in the air
that muriel almost thought she could see
the droplets
both angel and william had completely
disappeared
muriel could barely see through foggy
tears of loss and rage
she drove as fast as she dared barreling
down the near empty highway under a bowl
of stars
that seemed to shine down on her with
mocking indifference
she cursed herself with every filthy
word she could imagine
banging her hands on the steering wheel
until the skin on her palms split
until her fingers were slick with blood
why hadn't she believed them
when they said they'd find her anywhere
would it have made any difference if she
had
and why had she felt as though she were
being so brave when it was really her
children's lives she was toying with she
had no ready answers to these questions
and it felt as though her whole body
might explode in her frustration and
self-disgust
what else could she have done stayed at
the house and just let them take william
like her cowardly parents
she could never have forgiven herself if
she did that but she grimly realized as
she drove that perhaps her parents had
understood something that she had not
sometimes you simply had no choice
even though it had only been 70 miles to
the motel it seemed to take forever to
get back to the house
time seemed to be warping and bending in
bizarre ways
making her entire perception skewed and
dreamlike
she had no idea what time it was when
she finally turned down the dirt road
toward the farm
it was still dark but at this point that
didn't mean anything to her
she remembered how the women could make
it seem as though the night would never
end the car tires crunched noisily as
she steered toward the driveway
her body performing the function of
driving with no input from her brain at
all
she made no attempt to conceal her
approach the witches would be expecting
her
of that she was certain she was just as
sure of the fact that she would get
william back
or die in the attempt there were no
lights on in or around the house and its
rambling white structure hunkered in the
darkness like a massive ghostly predator
tensing to spring
just beyond the house muriel could see
the edge of the pond
the moonlight peppering its gentle
ripples there was no sound at all except
for the car's engine
and when muriel turned the key the
silence fell like a shroud
she took a cursory glance around to see
if there was anything that could be used
as a weapon
but she quickly abandoned the search and
got out of the car
even if she'd had a machine gun she
doubted it would be much use
muriel had left the headlights on to
guide her way and as soon as she was
clear of the car she broke into a run
her sneakers crashing through dead
leaves and shallow mud puddles
her elbow felt huge swollen inside her
sleeve but she tried to ignore the pain
as she stumbled through the yard she
thought she heard a splash
and the smell of the pond came into her
nostrils like an intruder
a nearly solid wall of stench she fought
back her revulsion and pressed forward
muriel rounded the corner of the house
at full clip and now the pond in its
entirety came into her view
huge and seemingly bottomless its
surface flat as black glass
the weeds and grasses at its perimeter
stirred in the light wind
and their whispers soon resolved
themselves into what sounded like words
muriel skidded to a halt she swore she
heard a baby crying
very far away william she called and her
voice volleyed back to her with a
sinister watery tinge
they came out of the pond like bubbles
of acid their reptilian heads emerging
slowly and in perfect synchrony
muriel watched horrified but transfixed
feeling as though she was under a spell
perhaps she even was
the hag's dripping faces were now clear
of the pond's surface
and all of their eyes opened in unison
the moonlight catching the orb so that
they appeared to be a sea of fireflies
or willow the wisps
muriel wanted to run away but couldn't
wanted to plunge into the filthy water
and tear the hags to pieces but couldn't
she could do nothing but stare as they
rose from the pond their scaly flesh
sparkling wet
their long hair hanging in straight
shimmering ropes
and then muriel's gaze focused at the
middle of the pond
her legs collapsed beneath her angel was
hovering there
her live naked body already beginning to
bloat and go pale
her brown eyes turning coppery
glimmering in the dark like cat's eyes
william was squalling in her arms his
lungs gurgling with pond water
muriel tried to speak but found she had
no voice
her knees dug into the ground cold mud
seeping through the fibers of her
clothes
she reached out with arms that seemed to
weigh a thousand pounds
the women approached the shore their
feet skimming lightly over the water
and soon stood in a well-organized knot
in the reeds at the pond's edge
angel was afforded pride of place
directly in the center of the group
the other women backed away a respectful
distance giving her room
she held the baby and stared down at her
mother
muriel shook her head her lips flopping
in feudal rhythm
no angel she wanted to say how could
they have done this to you
you can't do this not you not my angel
the girl seemed to have understood her
mother's thoughts for her eyes flickered
briefly and she glanced down at william
with what appeared to be uncertainty
but when she met muriel's gaze again all
semblance of the old angel had
disappeared
they've given me power she said and her
voice though seemingly choked with the
filth and gravel and slime that coated
the pond and everything in it
was as clear as a dagger sunk deep into
muriel's heart
they would have rewarded you this is all
that they asked for
just this angel held the baby out
slightly
he wriggled and whimpered and the women
looked down at him with plain lust and
hunger in their twinkling eyes
we could have been rich and powerful
together angel went on
her face a mask of mock regret you could
have had other babies
other girl babies they only want the
males
muriel clenched her fists in the mud
trying to will away the vision of
impossible reality before her
trying to convince herself that she was
still asleep back in the motel
room or back in her old room in this
house or even back in their old
apartment in the city
anywhere but crouching on the banks of
the black pond that had stolen her
childhood from her
i'm one of them now angel said clasping
the baby closer to her chest
william is going to make it official no
muriel managed to croak past the
paralysis that stilled her throat
the women were getting impatient now
eager to partake of the sacrifice of the
living infant flesh seductively
wriggling before them like a worm on a
hook
from among the seething crowd came
another voice and muriel recognized it
as belonging to the leader
the woman she'd spoken to a million
years ago or maybe it was the night
before
it has come to this she said in her
rattling frog song
it is your last chance join us now and
you will be with angel forever
refuse us and you will die like william
and like your brother before him
with the last scrap of willpower she
possessed muriel raised her head and met
the eyes of the hag with her own
a wordless look passed between them the
choice is made
the leader said the van's tires crunched
up the dirt driveway
sending dozing bugs and lizards
scurrying for cover
it was a hot day mid-summer and the sun
beat down like a punishment
thin tendrils of steam rose from the
surface of the pond behind the house
a young man climbed down from the
driver's side his hair shining like
polished copper
a moment later he lifted a little girl
who looked no more than five
and shared her father's new penny hair
color and soft kindly features
down to the ground where she immediately
darted around to the passenger side to
meet her mother
who was stepping out of the van with a
wistful smile on her face
she scooped up her daughter and looked
at the house's crumbling but still grand
facade
there was love in her face and hope
glowing there like a beacon
muriel raised her head a little more
above the surface of the pond
her long algae hair dripped water into
her opalescent eyes
but she barely noticed it the family had
gone inside the house muriel gazed up to
the second floor
to the nursery window where both
williams had once spent the whole of
their short lives
for a second she was sure she saw a
little girl's face behind the glass
staring back at her in pale silent
terror
muriel smiled and submerged her head
again clacking her sharp piranha teeth
[Music]
the idea that the extraordinary
narrative which has been called the
joyce armstrong fragment is an elaborate
practical joke
evolved by some unknown person cursed by
a perverted and sinister sense of humor
has now been abandoned by all who have
examined the matter
the most macabre and imaginative of
plotters would hesitate before
linking his morbid fancies with the
unquestioned and tragic facts which
reinforced the statement
though the assertions contained in it
are amazing and even monstrous
it is nonetheless forcing itself upon
the general intelligence that they are
true and that we must readjust our ideas
to the new situation
this world of ours appears to be
separated by a slight and precarious
margin of safety from a most singular
and unexpected danger
i will endeavor in this narrative which
reproduces the original document in its
necessarily somewhat fragmentary form
to lay before the reader the whole of
the facts up to date prefacing my
statement by saying that if there be any
who doubt the narrative of joyce
armstrong
there can be no question at all as to
the facts concerning lieutenant myrtle
r.n
and mr haye connor who undoubtedly met
their end in the manner described
the joyce armstrong fragment was found
in the field which is called lower
haycock
lying one mile to the westward of the
village of withiam upon the kenton
sussex border
it was on the 15th september last that
an agricultural laborer
james flynn in the employment of matthew
dodd farmer
of the chantry farm with him perceived a
briar pipe
lying near the footpath which skirts the
hedge in lower haycock
a few paces farther on he picked up a
pair of broken binocular glasses
finally among some nettles in the ditch
he caught sight of a flat canvas-backed
book
which proved to be a notebook with
detachable leaves some of which had come
loose and were fluttering along the base
of the hedge
these he collected but some including
the first were never recovered
and leave a deplorable hiatus in this
all-important statement
the notebook was taken by the laborer to
his master who in turn
showed it to dr j.h atherton of
hartfield
this gentleman at once recognized the
need for an expert examination
and the manuscript was forwarded to the
arrow club in london
where it now lies the first two pages of
the manuscript are missing
there is also one torn away at the end
of the narrative though none of these
affect the general coherence of the
story
it is conjectured that the missing
opening is concerned with the record of
mr joyce armstrong's qualifications as
an aeronaut
which can be gathered from other sources
and are admitted to be unsurpassed among
the air pilots of england
for many years he has been looked upon
as among the most daring and the most
intellectual of flying men
a combination which has enabled him to
both invent and test several new devices
including the common gyroscopic
attachment which is known by his name
the main body of the manuscript is
written neatly in ink
but the last few lines are in pencil and
are so ragged as to be hardly legible
exactly in fact as they might be
expected to appear if they were
scribbled off-hurriedly from the seat of
a moving airplane
there are it may be added several stains
both on the last page
and on the outside cover which had been
pronounced by the home office experts to
be blood
probably human and certainly mammalian
the fact that something closely
resembling the organism of malaria was
discovered in this blood
and that joyce armstrong is known to
have suffered from intermittent fever
is a remarkable example of the new
weapons which modern science has placed
in the hands of our detectives
and now a word as to the personality of
the author of this epoch making
statement
joyce armstrong according to the few
friends who really knew something of the
man
was a poet and a dreamer as well as a
mechanic and an inventor
he was a man of considerable wealth much
of which he had spent in the pursuit of
his aeronautical hobby
he had four private airplanes in his
hangers near devises
and is said to have made no fewer than
170 ascents in the course of last year
he was a retiring man with dark moods in
which he would avoid the society of his
fellows
captain dangerfield who knew him better
than anyone says that there were times
when his eccentricity threatened to
develop into something more serious
his habit of carrying a shotgun with him
in his airplane was one manifestation of
it
another was the morbid effect which the
fall of lieutenant myrtle had upon his
mind
myrtle who was attempting the height
record fell from an altitude of
something over thirty thousand feet
horrible to narrate his head was
entirely obliterated
though his body and limbs preserved
their configuration
and every gathering of airmen joyce
armstrong according to dangerfield
would ask with an enigmatic smile and
where prey
is myrtle's head on another occasion
after dinner
at the mess of the flying school on
salisbury plain he started a debate as
to what will be the most permanent
danger which airmen will have to
encounter
having listened to successive opinions
as to air pockets faulty construction
and overbanking he ended by shrugging
his shoulders and refusing to put
forward his own views
though he gave the impression that they
differed from any advanced by his
companions
it is worth remarking that after his own
complete disappearance
it was found that his private affairs
were arranged with a precision
which may show that he had a strong
premonition of disaster
with these essential explanations i will
now give the narrative
exactly as it stands beginning at page 3
of the blood soaked notebook
nevertheless when i dined at reims with
coselli and gustav raymond
i found that neither of them was aware
of any particular danger
in the higher layers of the atmosphere i
did not actually say what was in my
thoughts
but i got so near to it that if they had
any corresponding idea
they could not have failed to express it
but then they are two empty vainglorious
fellows
with no thought beyond seeing their
silly names in the newspaper
it is interesting to note that neither
of them had ever been much beyond the 20
000
foot level of course men have been
higher than this
both in balloons and in the ascent of
mountains it must be well above that
point that the airplane enters the
danger zone
always presuming that my premonitions
are correct
aeroplaning has been with us now for
more than 20 years and one might well
ask
why should this peril be only revealing
itself in our day
the answer is obvious in the old days of
weak engines
when 100 horsepower gnome or green was
considered ample for every need
the flights were very restricted now
that 300 horsepower is the rule
rather than the exception visits to the
upper layers have become easier and more
common
some of us can remember how in our youth
garos made a worldwide reputation by
attaining 19 000 feet
and it was considered a remarkable
achievement to fly over the alps
our standard now has been immeasurably
raised and there are 20 high flights for
one in former years
many of them have been undertaken with
impunity
the thirty thousand foot level has been
reached time after time with no
discomfort beyond cold and asthma
what does this prove a visitor might
descend upon this planet a thousand
times
and never see a tiger yet tigers exist
and if he chants to come down into a
jungle he might be devoured
there are jungles of the upper air and
there are worse things than tigers which
inhabit them
i believe in time they will map these
jungles accurately out
even at the present moment i could name
two of them
one of them lies over the pal biarets
district of france
another is just over my head as i write
here in my house in wiltshire
i rather think there is a third in the
hamburg weisbaden district
it was the disappearance of the airmen
that first set me thinking
of course everyone said that they had
fallen into the sea but that did not
satisfy me at all
first there was very a in france his
machine was found near bayonne but they
never got his body
there was the case of baxter also who
vanished though his engine and some of
the iron fixings were found in a wood in
leicestershire
in that case dr middleton of amesbury
who was watching the flight with a
telescope
declares that just before the clouds
obscured the view he saw the machine
which was at an enormous height
suddenly rise perpendicularly upwards in
a succession of jerks
in a manner that he would have thought
to be impossible that was the last scene
of baxter
there was a correspondence in the papers
but it never led to anything
there were several other similar cases
and then there was the death of hey
connor
what a cackle there was about an
unsolved mystery of the air
and what columns in the half penny
papers and yet how little was ever done
to get to the bottom of the business
he came down in a tremendous vole plane
from an unknown height
he never got off his machine and died in
his pilot's seat
died of what heart disease said the
doctors
rubbish hey connor's heart was as sound
as mine is
what did venables say venables was the
only man who was at his side when he
died
he said that he was shivering and looked
like a man who had been badly scared
died of fright said venables but could
not imagine what he was frightened about
only said one word to venables which
sounded like monstrous
they could make nothing of that at the
inquest but i could make something of it
monsters that was the last word of poor
harry haye connor
and he did die of fright just as
benables thought
and then there was myrtle's head do you
really believe
does anybody really believe that a man's
head could be driven clean into his body
by the force of a fall
well perhaps it may be possible but i
for one have never believed that it was
so
with myrtle and the grease upon his
clothes
all slimy with grease said somebody at
the inquest
queer that nobody got thinking after
that i did
but then i had been thinking for a good
long time
i've made three ascents how dangerfield
used to chaff me about my shotgun
but i've never been high enough now with
this new light paul varene machine and
it's 175 rover
i should easily touch the 30 thousand
tomorrow
i'll have a shot at the record maybe i
shall have a shot at something else as
well
of course it's dangerous if a fellow
wants to avoid danger he'd best keep out
of flying altogether
and subside finally into flannel
slippers in a dressing gown but i'll
visit the air jungle tomorrow
and if there's anything there i shall
know it if i return
i'll find myself a bit of a celebrity if
i don't
this notebook may explain what i am
trying to do and how i lost my life in
doing it but no drivel about
accidents or mysteries if you please
i chose my paul varene monoplane for the
job
there's nothing like a monoplane when
real work is to be done
beaumont found that out in the very
early days for one thing it doesn't mind
damp and the weather looks as if we
should be in the clouds all the time
it's a bonnie little model and answers
my hand like a tender mouthed horse
the engine is a 10 cylinder rotary rover
working up to 175.
it has all the modern improvements
enclosed fuselage
high curved landing skids brakes
gyroscopic steadiers and three speeds
worked by an alteration of the angle of
the planes upon the venetian blind
principle
i took a shotgun with me and a dozen
cartridges filled with buckshot
you should have seen the face of perkins
my old mechanic when i directed him to
put them in
i was dressed like an arctic explorer
with two jerseys under my overalls
thick socks inside my padded boots a
storm cap with flaps
and my talc goggles it was stifling
outside the hangers but i was going for
the summit of the himalayas and had to
dress for the part
perkins knew there was something on and
implored me to take him with me
perhaps i should if i were using the
biplane but a monoplane is a one-man
show
if you want to get the last foot of life
out of it of course i took an oxygen bag
the man who goes for the altitude record
without one will either be frozen or
smothered or both
i had a good look at the planes the
rudder bar and the elevating lever
before i got in
everything was in order so far as i
could see then i switched on my engine
and found that she was running sweetly
when they let her go she rose almost at
once upon the lowest speed
i circled my home field once or twice
just to warm her up
and then with a wave to perkins and the
others i flattened out my planes and put
her on her highest
she skimmed like a swallow downwind for
eight or ten miles
until i turned her nose up a little and
she began to climb in a great spiral for
the cloud bank above me
it's all important to rise slowly and
adapt yourself to the pressure as you go
it was a close warm day for an english
september and there was the hush and
heaviness of impending rain
now and then there came sudden puffs of
wind from the southwest
one of them so gusty and unexpected that
it caught me napping
and turned me half round for an instant
i remember the time when gusts and
whirls and air pockets used to be things
of danger
before we learned to put an
overmastering power into our engines
just as i reached the cloud banks with
the altimeter marking 3000
down came the rain my word how it poured
it drummed upon my wings and lashed
against my face blurring my glasses so
that i could hardly see
i got down onto a low speed for it was
painful to travel against it
as i got higher it became hail and i had
to turn tail to it
one of my cylinders was out of action a
dirty plug i should imagine
but still i was rising steadily with
plenty of power
after a bit the trouble passed whatever
it was and i heard the full
deep-throated purr
the ten singing as one that's where the
beauty of our modern silencers comes in
we can at last control our engines by
ear how they squeal and squeak and sob
when they are in trouble
all those cries for help were wasted in
the old days when every sound was
swallowed up by the monstrous racket of
the machine
if only the early aviators could come
back to see the beauty and perfection of
the mechanism
which had been bought at the cost of
their lives
about 9 30 i was nearing the clouds down
below me all blurred and shattered with
rain
lay the vast expanse of salisbury plain
half a dozen flying machines were doing
hack work at the thousand foot level
looking like little black swallows
against the green background
i dare say they were wondering what i
was doing up in cloud land
suddenly a grey curtain drew across
beneath me and the wet folds of vapors
were swirling around my face
it was clearly cold and miserable but i
was above the hailstorm
and that was something gained the cloud
was as dark and thick as a london fog
in my anxiety to get clear i cocked her
nose up until the automatic alarm bell
rang
and i actually began to slide backwards
my soft and dripping wings had made me
heavier than i thought
but presently i was in lighter cloud and
soon had cleared the first layer
there was a second opal-colored and
fleecy at a great height above my head
a white unbroken ceiling above and a
dark unbroken floor below
with a monoplane laboring upwards upon a
vast spiral between them
it is deadly lonely in these cloud
spaces once a great flight of some small
water birds went past me
flying very fast to the westwards the
quick whir of their wings and their
musical cry were cheery to my ear
i fancy that they were teal but i'm a
wretched zoologist
now that we humans have become birds we
must really learn to know our brethren
by
sight the wind down beneath me whirled
and swayed the broad cloud plane
once a great eddy formed in it a
whirlpool of vapor
and threw it as down a funnel i caught
sight of the distant world
a large white biplane was passing at a
vast depth beneath me
i fancy it was the morning mail service
between bristol and london
then the drift swirled inwards again and
the great solitude was unbroken
just after 10 i touched the lower edge
of the upper cloud stratum
it consisted of fine diaphanous vapor
drifting swiftly from the westwards
the wind had been steadily rising all
this time and it was now blowing a sharp
breeze
28 an hour by my gauge already it was
very cold
though my altimeter only marked nine
thousand the engines were working
beautifully and we went droning steadily
upwards
the cloud bank was thicker than i
expected but at last it thinned out into
a golden mist before me
and then in an instant i had shot out
from it and there was an unclouded sky
and a brilliant sun above my head
all blue and gold above all shining
silver below
one vast glimmering plane as far as my
eyes could reach
it was a quarter past 10 o'clock and the
barograph needle pointed to 12
800. up i went and up my ears
concentrated upon the deep purring of my
motor
my eyes busy always with the watch the
revolution indicator
the petrol lever and the oil pump no
wonder aviators are said to be a
fearless race
with so many things to think of there is
no time to trouble about oneself
about this time i noted how unreliable
is the compass when above a certain
height from earth
at fifteen thousand feet mine was
pointing east and a point south
the sun and the wind gave me my true
bearings
i had hoped to reach an eternal
stillness in these high altitudes
but with every thousand feet of ascent
the gale grew stronger
my machine groaned and trembled in every
joint and rivet as she faced it
and swept away like a sheet of paper
when i banged her on the turn
skimming downwind at a greater pace
perhaps than ever mortal man has moved
yet i had always to turn again and tack
up in the wind's eye
for it was not merely a height record
that i was after by all my calculations
it was above little wiltshire that my
air jungle lay
and all my labor might be lost if i
struck the outer layers at some farther
point
when i reached the 19 000 foot level
which was about midday
the wind was so severe that i looked
with some anxiety to the stays of my
wings
expecting momentarily to see them snap
or slacken
i even cast loose the parachute behind
me and fastened its hook
into the ring of my leather belt so as
to be ready for the worst
now was the time when a bit of scamped
work by the mechanic is paid for by the
life of the aeronaut
but she held together bravely every cord
and strut was humming and vibrating
like so many harp strings but it was
glorious to see how
for all the beating and the buffeting
she was still the conqueror of nature
and the mistress of the sky
there is surely something divine in man
himself that he should rise so superior
to the limitations which creation seem
to impose
rise too by such unselfish heroic
devotion
as this air conquest has shown talk of
human degeneration
when has such a story as this been
written in the annals of our race
these were the thoughts in my head as i
climbed that monstrous inclined plane
with the wind sometimes beating in my
face
and sometimes whistling behind my ears
while the cloud land beneath me fell
away to such a distance that the folds
and hummocks of silver
had all smoothed out into one flat
shining plane
but suddenly i had a horrible and
unprecedented experience
i have known before what it is to be in
what our neighbors have called a torbial
but never on a scale such as this that
huge sweeping river of wind of which i
have spoken
had as it appears whirlpools within it
which were as monstrous as itself
without a moment's warning i was dragged
suddenly into the heart of one
i spun round for a minute or two with
such velocity that i almost lost my
senses
and then fell suddenly left wing
foremost down the vacuum funnel in the
center
i dropped like a stone and lost nearly a
thousand feet
it was only my belt that kept me in my
seat and the shock and breathlessness
left me hanging half insensible over the
side of the fuselage
but i'm always capable of a supreme
effort it is my one great merit as an
aviator
i was conscious that the descent was
slower the whirlpool was a cone rather
than a funnel and i had come to the apex
with a terrific wrench throwing my
weight all to one side
i leveled my planes and brought her head
away from the wind
in an instant i had shot out of the
eddies and was skimming down the sky
then shaken but victorious i turned her
nose up
and began once more my steady grind on
the upward spiral
i took a large sweep to avoid the danger
spot of the whirlpool
and soon i was safely above it just
after one o'clock i was 21 000 feet
above the sea level
to my great joy i had topped the gale
and with every hundred feet of ascent
the air grew stiller
on the other hand it was very cold and i
was conscious of that peculiar nausea
which goes with rarefaction of the air
for the first time i unscrewed the mouth
of my oxygen bag and took an occasional
whiff of the glorious gas
i could feel it running like a cordial
through my veins and i was exhilarated
almost to the point of drunkenness
i shouted and sang as i soared upwards
into the cold still outer world
it is very clear to me that the
insensibility which came upon glycer and
in a lesser degree upon coxwell
when in 1862 they ascended in a balloon
to the height of 30 000 feet
was due to the extreme speed with which
a perpendicular ascent is made
doing it at an easy gradient and
accustoming oneself to the lessened
barometric pressure by slow degrees
there are no such dreadful symptoms at
the same great height i found that even
without my oxygen inhaler i could
breathe without undue distress
it was bitterly cold however and my
thermometer was at zero fahrenheit
at 1 30 i was nearly seven miles above
the surface of the earth
and still ascending steadily i found
however that the rarefied air was giving
markedly less support to my planes
and that my angle of ascent had to be
considerably lowered in consequence
it was already clear that even with my
light weight and strong engine power
there was a point in front of me where i
should be held to make matters worse one
of my spark plugs was in trouble again
and there was intermittent misfiring in
the engine
my heart was heavy with the fear of
failure
it was about that time that i had a most
extraordinary experience
something whizzed past me in a trail of
smoke and exploded with a loud hissing
sound
sending forth a cloud of steam for the
instant i could not imagine what had
happened
then i remembered that the earth is
forever being bombarded by meteor stones
and would be hardly inhabitable where
they not in nearly every case turned to
vapor in the outer layers of the
atmosphere
here is a new danger for the high
altitude man for two others past me when
i was nearing the 40 000 foot mark
i cannot doubt that at the edge of the
earth's envelope the risk would be a
very real one
my barograph needle marked 41 300
when i became aware that i could go no
farther physically the strain was not
as yet greater than i could bear but my
machine had reached its limit
the attenuated air gave no firm support
to the wings
and the least tilt developed into side
slip while she seemed sluggish on her
controls
possibly had the engine been at its best
another thousand feet
might have been within our capacity but
it was still misfiring
and two out of the ten cylinders
appeared to be out of action
if i had not already reached the zone
for which i was searching then i should
never see it upon this journey
but was it not possible that i had
attained it soaring in circles like a
monstrous hawk upon the 40 000 foot
level
i let the monoplane guide herself and
with my manheim glass i made a careful
observation of my surroundings
the heavens were perfectly clear there
was no indication of those dangers which
i had imagined
i have said that i was soaring in
circles it struck me suddenly that i
would do well to take a wider sweep
and open up a new air tract if the
hunter entered an earth jungle he would
drive through it if he wished to find
his game
my reasoning had led me to believe that
the air jungle which i had imagined lay
somewhere over wiltshire
this should be to the south and west of
me i took my bearings from the sun
for the compass was hopeless and no
trace of earth was to be seen
nothing but the distant silver cloud
plane however i got my direction as best
i might and kept her head straight to
the mark
i reckon that my petrol supply would not
last for more than another hour or so
but i could afford to use it to the last
drop since a single magnificent wall
plane could at any time take me to the
earth
suddenly i was aware of something new
the air in front of me had lost its
crystal clearness
it was full of long ragged wisps of
something which i can only compare to
very fine cigarette smoke
it hung about in wreaths and coils
turning and twisting slowly in the
sunlight
as the monoplane shot through it i was
aware of a faint taste of oil upon my
lips
and there was a greasy scum upon the
woodwork of the machine
some infinitely fine organic matter
appeared to be suspended in the
atmosphere
there was no life there it was encoed
and diffuse
extending for many square acres and then
fringing off into the void
no it was not life but might it not be
the remains of life
above all might it not be the food of
life of monstrous life
even as the humble greece of the ocean
is the food for the mighty whale
the thought was in my mind when my eyes
looked upwards and i saw the most
wonderful vision that every man has seen
can i hope to convey it to you even as i
saw it myself last thursday
conceive a jellyfish such as sails in
our summer seas
bell-shaped and of enormous size far
larger i should judge than the dome of
saint paul's
it was of a light pink color veined with
a delicate green
but the whole huge fabric so tenuous
that it was but a fairy outline against
the dark blue sky
it pulsated with a delicate and regular
rhythm
from it there depended two long drooping
green tentacles
which swayed slowly backwards and
forwards this gorgeous vision passed
gently with noiseless dignity over my
head
as light and fragile as a soap bubble
and drifted upon its stately way
i had half turned my monoplane that i
might look after this beautiful creature
when in a moment i found myself amidst a
perfect fleet of them
of all sizes but none so large as the
first
some were quite small but the majority
about as big as an average balloon
and with much the same curvature at the
top there was in them a delicacy of
texture and coloring which reminded me
of the finest venetian glass
pale shades of pink and green were the
prevailing tints but all had a lovely
iridescence where the sun shimmered
through their dainty forms
some hundreds of them drifted past me a
wonderful fairy squadron of strange
unknown argosies of the sky
creatures whose forms and substance were
so attuned to these pure heights
that one could not conceive anything so
delicate with an actual sight or sound
of earth
but soon my attention was drawn to a new
phenomenon
the serpents of the outer air these were
long
thin fantastic coils of vapor-like
material
which turned and twisted with great
speed flying round and round at such a
pace that the eyes could hardly follow
them
some of these ghost-like creatures were
20 or 30 feet long
but it was difficult to tell their girth
for their outline was so hazy
that it seemed to fade away into the air
around them
these air snakes were of a very light
gray or smoke color with some darker
lines within
which gave the impression of a definite
organism
one of them whisked past my very face
and i was conscious of a cold clammy
contact
but their composition was so
unsubstantial that i could not connect
them with any thought of physical danger
any more than the beautiful bell-like
creatures which had preceded them
there was no more solidity in their
frames than in the floating spume from a
broken wave
but a more terrible experience was in
store for me
floating downwards from a great height
there came a purplish patch of vapor
small as i saw at first but rapidly
enlarging as it approached me
until it appeared to be hundreds of
square feet in size
though fashioned of some transparent
jelly-like substance
it was nonetheless of much more definite
outline and solid consistence than
anything which i had seen before
there were more traces too of a physical
organization
especially two vast shadowy circular
plates upon either side
which may have been eyes and a perfectly
solid white projection between them
which was as curved and cruel as the
beak of a vulture
the whole aspect of this monster was
formidable and threatening
and it kept changing its color from a
very light mauve to a dark angry purple
so thick that it cast a shadow as it
drifted between my monoplane and the sun
on the upper curve of its huge body
there were three great projections
which i can only describe as enormous
bubbles and i was convinced as i looked
at them that they were charged with some
extremely light gas
which served to buoy up the misshapen
and semi-solid mass in the rarefied air
the creature moved swiftly along keeping
pace easily with the monoplane
and for 20 miles or more it formed my
horrible escort
hovering over me like a bird of prey
which is waiting to pounce
its method of progression done so
swiftly that it was not easy to follow
was to throw out a long glutinous
streamer in front of it
which in turn seemed to draw forward the
rest of the writhing body
so elastic and gelatinous was it that
never for two successive minutes was it
the same shape
and yet each change made it more
threatening and loathsome than the last
i knew that it meant mischief every
purple flash of its hideous body told me
so
the vague goggling eyes which were
turned always upon me
were cold and merciless in their vicid
hatred
i dipped the nose of my monoplane
downwards to escape it
as i did so as quick as a flash there
shot out a long tentacle from this mass
of floating blubber
and it fell as light insinuous as a
whiplash across the front of my machine
there was a loud hiss as it lay for a
moment across the hot engine
and it whisked itself into the air again
while the huge flat body drew itself
together as if in sudden pain
i dipped into a nose dive but again a
tentacle fell over the monoplane and was
shorn off by the propeller
as easily as it might have cut through a
smoke reef a long gliding sticky
serpent-like coil came from behind and
caught me around the waist
dragging me out of the fuselage i tore
at it my fingers sinking into the smooth
glue-like surface
and for an instant i disengaged myself
but only to be caught round the boot by
another coil
which gave me a jerk that tilted me
almost onto my back
as i fell over i blazed off both barrels
of my gun
though indeed it was like attacking an
elephant with a peashooter to imagine
that any human weapon could
[ __ ] that mighty bulk and yet i aimed
better than i knew
for with a loud report one of the great
blisters upon the creature's back
exploded with the puncture of the
buckshot it was very clear that my
conjecture was right
and that these vast clear bladders were
distended with some lifting gas
for in an instant the huge cloud-like
body turned sideways
writhing desperately to find its balance
while the white beak snapped and gaped
in horrible fury
but already i had shot away on the
steepest glide that i dared to
attempt my engine still full on the
flying propeller and the force of
gravity shooting me downwards like an
arrow light
far behind me i saw a dull purplish
smudge growing swiftly smaller
and merging into the blue sky behind it
i was safe out of the deadly jungle of
the outer air
once out of danger i throttled my engine
for nothing tears a machine to pieces
quicker than running on full power from
a height
it was a glorious spiral vole plane from
nearly eight miles of altitude
first to the level of the silver cloud
bank then to that of the storm cloud
beneath it
and finally in beating rain to the
surface of the earth
i saw the bristol channel beneath me as
i broke from the clouds
but having still some petrol in my tank
i got 20 miles inland
before i found myself stranded in a
field half a mile from the village of
ashcomb
there i got three tins of petrol from a
passing motor car
and at 10 minutes past six that evening
i alighted gently in my own home meadow
it devises
after such a journey as no mortal upon
earth has ever yet taken and lived to
tell the tale
i have seen the beauty and i have seen
the horror of the heights and greater
beauty and greater horror than that
is not within the ken of man and now it
is my plan to go once again before i
give my results to the world
my reason for this is that i must surely
have something to show by way of proof
before i lay such a tale before my
fellow men it is true that others will
soon follow and will confirm what i have
said
and yet i should wish to carry
conviction from the first
those lovely iridescent bubbles of the
air should not be hard to capture
they drift slowly upon their way and the
swift monoplane could intercept their
leisurely course
it is likely enough that they would
dissolve in the heavier layers of the
atmosphere
and that some small heap of amorphous
jelly might be all that i should bring
to earth with me
and yet something there would surely be
by which i could substantiate my story
yes i will go even if i run a risk by
doing so
these purple horrors would not seem to
be numerous it is probable that i shall
not see one
if i do i shall die of it once at the
worst there is always the shotgun and my
knowledge of
here a page of the manuscript is
unfortunately missing
on the next page is written in large
straggling writing
43 000 feet i shall never see earth
again
they are beneath me three of them god
help me
it is a dreadful death to die
such in its entirety is the joyce
armstrong statement
of the man nothing has since been seen
pieces of his shattered monoplane
have been picked up in the preserves of
mr bud lushington
upon the borders of kent and sussex
within a few miles of the spot where the
notebook was discovered
if the unfortunate aviator's theory is
correct that this air jungle as he
called it
existed only over the southwest of
england then it would seem that he had
fled from it at the full speed of his
motto plane
but had been overtaken and devoured by
these horrible creatures
at some spot in the outer atmosphere
above the place where the grim relics
were found
the picture of that monoplane skimming
down the sky with a nameless terrors
flying as swiftly beneath it
and cutting it off always from the earth
while they gradually closed in upon
their victim
is one upon which a man who valued his
sanity would prefer not to dwell
there are many as i am aware who still
jeer at the facts which i have here set
down
but even they must admit that joyce
armstrong has disappeared
and i would commend to them his own
words this notebook may explain what i
am trying to do
and how i lost my life in doing it but
no drivel about
accidents or mysteries if you please
you